[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Welcome to the
Data Science Hangout.
I hope everyone's
having a great week.
If we haven't met yet,
I'm Rachel Dempsey,
I lead our pro
community here at Posit.
This is our open space
to chat about data science leadership,
questions you're facing,
and getting to hear what's
going on in the world of data
across many different industries.
And we're here the same
time, same place,
every Thursday.
So if you are watching this
as a recording sometime in the future,
it will be a link where you can
add it to your calendar below as well.
Together,
we're all dedicated to
making this a welcoming environment
for everybody.
And so we love to hear
from everybody no matter your level
of experience
or area of work or industry.
I like to say that it is
totally OK to just listen in
though, if you want.
But there's also three ways you
can jump in and ask questions,
or provide your
own perspective.
So you can raise your
hand here on Zoom,
and I'll be on
the lookout here.
You can put questions
in the Zoom chat.
And if you're, maybe,
in a coffee shop or your
dogs barking or something,
just put a little star next
to your question in the Zoom chat,
and I can read it instead. Otherwise,
I'll just call on you to
jump in and add some context.
And then lastly, we
also have a slide,
a link where you
can ask questions anonymously.
And I see Hannah just shared
that in the chat here.
But thank you so much, Matt,
for joining us here today
as our featured leader.
Matt Frazier is former
chief analytics and underwriting
officer, currently
a strategic advisor
at Pie Insurance.
And Matt, I'd love
to have you, maybe,
kick us off by introducing
yourself and sharing a little
bit about your role and
something you like to do
outside of work too.
- Sure.
So I'm Matt Fraser.
I actually started in
data science in 2008
right after the financial
crisis. Prior to that,
I was more of an insurance guy.
I actually have a background in philosophy,
specifically, metaphysics.
And so, I'm sort of a
Carl Popperian at heart,
if anybody knows
who Karl Popper is,
who is the first
empirical skeptic. And so,
I sort of transitioned my
empirical skepticism over into
data science and started to
learn it in 2008. Before that,
I carried a number of executive
positions at different
insurance companies in the
underwriting space.
At that point in time,
from let's say, 1998 through 2008,
I did not know of an
insurance company that was actually doing
any predictive modeling at
all, and it is still the case.
That, really, the National
carriers are using AI,
they're using data science,
they're using predictive
modeling. But most of
the smaller mutuals, right?
The ones that are only in
a couple of states are really
using other predictive modeling
software and service companies
to do all of their
predictive modelings. So
data science was a
sort of an obvious
transition after I made it.
But I had no idea what the
heck it was before I got into it.
I was just a philosophy guy. I
was a language guy. I love language.
And I love understanding what is
knowable and what isn't knowable, right?
But I didn't really realize
that you could translate that
into mathematics
until I got into
a company called
Valen Technologies.
So I sort of got out
of the insurance industry and went
into a company that
was adjacent to the insurance
industry. Actually, selling to
insurance companies
predictive analytics and
data science solutions.
So before that,
I was pretty good on
the actuarial side.
I'm not a classically
trained actuary at heart,
but I was the director
of pricing at a number of
different insurance companies
as I sort of progressed
through my career.
And so I got pretty
good at using Excel.
I got pretty good at
grinding through data.
I get pretty good at
philosophically understanding
data and understanding
what it meant if certain
data had low integrity versus high
integrity and things like that.
I was really good
at data wrangling.
But I didn't have any
idea what a GLM was.
And don't ask me to write
any formulas down because I let you
guys and I let the data
scientists do that, right?
But I'm pretty good at picking
models apart because of my
empirical skepticism that
I learned at a very early,
sort of, age through
college and high school.
My dad was a physician. He
always used to hammer me on,
hey, are you sure you know
that? Do you know that?
Or do you think you
know that, right?
Do you believe you know
that because beliefs can be wrong?
And so, when I was at Valen,
I was able to get trained
by a former chief modeling officer
at Capital One. Valen Technologies,
one of the major investors
was Nigel Morris, who is one
of the co-founders of Capital One.
And Capital One was sort of one
of the first banks that got into
machine learning, got
into predictive modeling
on the credit
card side. And so,
they had a very
robust understanding.
There were one of the
early adopters let's say,
in the banking space and
the fintech space of actually using
predictive models in order
to create a competitive advantage
or arbitrage opportunity within the
credit card space. And so,
we were able to really
capitalize on that connection
with Capital One.
We're able to take some
really smart people from Capital One,
bring them into Valen. And
I really learned on the job
from one of the former
chief modeling officers on
the commercial auto and auto
finance side from Capital One.
And
the second I got into it,
I absolutely loved it. I mean,
Valen was my favorite job. The
second I got into data science,
I was like, Oh, God,
this is what I've been
missing my whole life, right?
Like, I love the language,
but to be able to blend the
language and the math together,
the language and
the data together,
and actually produce
something that gives another
company a moat or a
competitive advantage in a marketplace--
man, that's really cool. Like,
I can actually take things
from the philosophy side where all
you're really doing is creating
more questions for yourself and
actually translating that into real
durable value in the world.
Like something that's tangible
that can be seen through
dollars and cents, which
is super duper excited.
I got really
excited about that.
And then, I
translated that into
Pie Insurance.
I was one of what I would
call the silent co-founder
at Pie. We took all of the
learnings that we were able to
extract from Valen
Technologies,
working with about 56 different
insurance companies in the
property and casualty space.
And we translated that
into building durable models that
created a competitive advantage
and an arbitrage opportunity
for Pie Insurance Pie
started in-- oh, gosh,
I want to say it was 2018
now. So we're now writing
about 300 million.
We're on the path to about
350, maybe, $400 million this year.
And I believe we're
the fastest growing
and quickest,
most capitalized InsurTech
that has ever
existed. So, somehow,
I was able to take that
philosophy degree translate it
into data science, create
a competitive advantage, and
raise a whole bunch of money
and create a company that now employs.
Unfortunately,
we just went through what
we call a reduction force.
But we had about 460
employees. We now have
about 400 employees now.
And I think that's the end
of the cutting, so far.
But
I've been very pleased with what
I've been able to do and
what I've been able to
learn in data science.
And I'm just looking forward to
a lot more learning
opportunities as we move forward.
Now, you asked what
do I like to do?
- Yeah.
- Skiing, fly fishing,
hiking. I like to be outside.
So as long as it's outside,
and it's sort of more
of a single sport,
I really like that
kind of a thing.
I'm not a big team sports guy.
That's not--
that I'm not big on
teams because I'm huge on teams,
I just don't play a
lot of team sports.
I play tennis and things like that
are more double or single kind of thing.
- Well, where are you outside
right now in your background? Your--
virtual background.
- This is Wadi Rum, so
this is right near Petra in Jordan.
And I try to keep it fresh
with all my background.
So I have goofy backgrounds
like Animal House and
Casablanca and other
things like that.
This one just happened to
be up on my Zoom today.
- Well, thank you so much for
joining us today, Matt. I feel like--
I can feel the energy
from you and excitement coming through
the computer. So thank you
for bringing the energy here today.
Something I
really wanted to ask
you about, initially,
because this is something that comes
up quite a bit in the
Data Science Hangouts.
So I know you wrote your
bio for the hangout with ChatGPT,
so I feel like this is a
good place to start off.
But I'd love to hear
your thoughts on chat-- ChatGPT,
but also AI in general.
And how you think it may
impact the insurance industry.
- OK. I'll start
with in general,
and then we'll go
into insurance.
There's
a lot of people on
both sides of one particular argument,
and that is whether ChatGPT
has the latest sort of tangible
instantiation of AI, right?
Is AI going to take
over the world?
Are we going to live in a
terminator universe where AI
eventually is significantly smarter
than us and somehow
grows in tension?
I'm in the camp that
I think that artificial intelligence
and large language models
and the like are
going to be a
benefit to society.
They are not going to be
a threat to society. Now,
do we have to be careful?
Of course, right?
Human beings are never at
a space morally where we are
technologically. And so, the technology
is going to force us
to reevaluate or trans evaluate
are scale of values. We're
going to have to understand
what can be done,
and we're going to have to
understand how we can make sure
that we are distributing things
like AI and some equitable manner.
And
in insurance, this is
a real big problem,
especially in the
industry that I'm in.
We have a lot of small
carriers out there,
but they don't have
any of the data.
There are about five or six
or seven very large carriers that beat
all of the small
carriers up with data.
Now, we're not talking
about large language models,
we're literally just
talking about simple GLMs.
We're talking about any of
the normal machine learning
algorithms, whether they
be gradient boosting,
whether they be random forest.
Whether they be other
elastic nets or tree models,
it doesn't really matter.
Whoever has the most data wins.
Usually in insurance,
right? Into insurance,
it's a little bit weird.
We have a zero point
inflation on all of the distributions
that we're looking at.
So, in most cases, when
you look at an insurance policy,
about 75% to 97% of the time,
the right answer is zero,
right? People just
don't have losses.
But when they have losses,
some of them can be
very significant.
And they can really hurt
businesses. They can hurt individuals.
And that's what
insurance is for.
Insurance is for that highly
unlikely event that is
catastrophic, right?
That's where insurance
really helps society.
And at the end of the day,
that's a really interesting problem
to solve for a lot of
data scientists, right?
The issue is,
that most of the carriers that
are out there that aren't the
big national guys, don't have
enough data in order to do
that, right? And that's
a big problem because you
can use that to your advantage
to become a monopoly.
And if you see Hartford,
if you see travelers,
if you see Liberty Mutual,
if you see Swiss Re or some
of the large reinsurers,
they have all the data.
So they can almost always build
better models because, at this point,
the algorithm doesn't matter as much
as how much data you have
and the integrity of that data.
It's really important to
understand your problem space
and to think very deeply
about that problem space where you
can go get data in order to
solve that problem in space. And so,
at Valen Analytics,
when I was there,
we actually created
a consortium data set,
and that was specifically
for small carriers.
It was to allow small carriers
and new entrants to the
insurance market to be able
to take advantage of large data
sets with people who had
subject matter expertise and
data science expertise to be
able to deploy models for those
small carriers and democratize
the insurance space,
to really allow new entrants
and innovation into that space.
If anybody knows anything
about the insurance space now,
the one thing that is
very, very clear is that,
it is probably one of
the slowest-moving industries on the planet.
And the reason that it's
one of the slowest-moving industries
on the planet is because,
there are five carriers
that hold all the data,
and they don't have to move.
They already have a
durable advantage over everybody else.
And so, they're not
really interested in innovating.
Now,
that's changed in the last
decade quite a bit because of
people like Valen,
and other software as a
service companies that are coming out,
or data sciences service
companies that are building
consortium data sets. Or
finding novel ways to use
public source data in
order to create large,
either empirical or
synthetic data sets,
that can bring value to bear
for some of these smaller
carriers, and allow
new entrants into
the industry. And what I
think that's going to do is--
first of all, it's going
to disrupt the industry.
That's why
the insurance industry has
coined a new term called
Insurtech, right?
Most of those InsurTech
companies are not just tech.
They should call it like
insure data or insure machine learning
or insure AI because that's
really what all of the
Insurtechs are doing,
they're using AI,
they're using machine
learning. It's really not AI,
it's machine learning, right?
It's building models on large
consortium or
synthetic data sets
in order to extract or
provide that value to smaller carriers
so they can compete
with the big guys.
Because most of the small
guys, either just, sort of, larger
along, like, barely soldier on
through the snow in Siberia, right?
Or they just get subsumed or bought
or acquired by some of the large guys.
And so, they just get
bigger, and they continue their monopoly.
What I'm really interested
in is making sure that data
science and large available
data sets can actually
democratize the industry that I'm
in because I believe it's
an unfair industry.
And I believe it's a quasi
cabal of monopolists that are
actually controlling
this industry.
And that is true in
many, many industries.
And I think there's going
to be a huge opportunity,
especially with the
advent of ChatGPT
and these LLMs for software as
a service companies to go out
and very easily get customers
in order to optimize those
standardized LLMs,
and do other data science
and machine learning projects for
these companies, deploy
those models for them,
and allow them to hit those models
with APIs and bring that value to bear.
Now,
there's a lot more insurance
companies that are looking to create
data science practices
inside of their own carriers.
The biggest issue is you have
to get a critical mass of data
in order to do that. I mean,
Pie is writing $350
million in premium a year,
and we don't have enough data.
We actually had to go to
Valen to purchase additional
consortium data in order to
build a robust model, right?
Because of that 0-point mass.
So you have to be-- not
just a slightly big insurance company.
You have to be about a six
$700 million insurance company
that's been writing for three to
five years at that level in
order to have enough data
to build a really robust model.
And so that's where I
think using consortium data sets or
novel data sets or even some
of these new algorithms, like,
adversarial
algorithms to create synthetic data
sets that are very closely
mirrored to the
underlying empirical data,
to be able to bootstrap and
expand that data to be able to
make more robust models.
There's a lot of companies that
I've talked to that are coming
out with things like that.
And Pie is actively doing a
lot of POCs with those types of
companies to find out.
Whether we can take our
smaller data set and we can
exponentiate that data set so that
we have a much larger data
set to be able to
build models on.
- Really interesting. Thank you.
I see Liz had a question.
A follow-up question
in the chat. Liz,
do you want to jump in here?
- Sure.
So I worked in the Casualty
Space as an analyst for five
years. And I'm actually
about to have an interview
next week with four junior data
scientists trying to
get back in the space.
But I was curious
regarding ChatGPT.
I think there's a lot
of people doing, like,
parrot programming
and stuff with that.
And they maybe don't realize
that when they submit a
question or a
prompt to ChatGPT,
if it's not a locally
hosted LLM that the host is
owning that data,
whether they're allowed to or not
and that creates a huge exposure.
I'm curious if you have any
thoughts or comments about that
liability and that exposure.
- Yeah. That's actually
a massive liability.
And I don't think that
the insurance space is
going to capitalize on ChatGPT,
especially in the pricing
and underwriting domain until
there is assurances that the data
that they put in to train
specific instances of the LLM
are going to be protected
in some way and cordoned off
from the larger language model.
So, right now,
I know that there are several companies
that I'm working with are like, well,
we don't want to do anything
until we have absolute
assurance that our data is
safe and that no one else can
gain any advantage through the use
of us putting that data into,
right? Some can--
some container or some space that
allows us to train those LLMs.
And I think that is where a
lot of new companies are going to
be extremely successful
is going to be
prompt engineering and specialization
of those larger language models,
sort of, the base models.
And making sure that they're doing
that in such a way that
they can make sure that
they have an understanding of the
custody of the data.
And that they can either
tokenize that data or make sure
that data doesn't get into
the larger pool of data that's
being used in order to
optimize the underlying base LLM. It's
really important.
I think until that happens,
ChatGPT is going to
be used more for--
in insurance, it's going to
be used for automating processes
around changing policies, right?
Making sure that the language
in the chat functionality goes
back and forth very smoothly
without any human intervention.
But I don't think that
it's really going to the--
the insurance industry is really
going to capitalize on ChatGPT
as an underwriting
agent, right?
Until all of that
data can is safe
and is completely separated
and mutually exclusive from the
larger pool of data.
That's going to be a
really important piece of the puzzle
that some of this software,
as a service companies,
are going to have
to figure out.
I mean, I know that I've
already told my team at Pie, and
I work with several other
carriers, and I've told them, oh,
don't put your data into
chat right now because then
everybody gets to use it,
right? Like, this thing learns. And--
- It's like, it's also about
work product and stuff, you know?
- Oh, totally.
- If
you say, oh, hey,
I need help fixing this chain
ladder model or whatever,
but you have a little bit
of secret sauce in there,
and then someone else asks,
and then, boom, your secret's out,
and you lose an edge.
- That's exactly right. I
mean, even in our business,
we have a very
specialized transformation of the target
space that we use for our
line of business worker's
compensation. And we don't
want anybody to know that.
That's a specialized
transformation.
I haven't seen anybody
else in the industry used.
It works really, really well.
I don't want to give that
information to anybody, right?
And the second I
pop it in there,
it's possible for
someone to extract that.
Unless new technology and
updated knowledge is actually
given to the insurance industry
by some of, you know,
a new company, a new individual,
that's working with
these companies that actually
understands how to specialize
these LLMs without delivering
the data to the
larger baseline model.
I personally don't know
how to do that yet.
But I know that that's
something that's being talked
about very actively and heavily
within the insurance space.
Well, how do we take
advantage of this?
And if we're going to
take advantage of this,
how do we not give
away our secret sauce
and take advantage of
it, at the same time?
- Oh, like, from
my perspective,
it seems like the best
use would be like having a
privately hosted
LLM that serves as,
like a communication agent
for people filing claims or
whatever in their
apps, you know?
Where it's kind of low stakes.
You can segment the data,
make sure it doesn't get
out, but you also have clear
knowledgeable communication happening
that's automated and
understandable.
And the higher-end
stuff, like, maybe,
we'll get there, but that's
like pretty not there right now.
- I think that's exactly right.
The other big piece of the
puzzle that is going to be
there is, right now, almost
all insurance companies are--
all insurance companies that
are using machine learning, are
using it in order to
straight through process some accounts.
But there's always a human
being overlay, right?
So you allow the model to
make about 30% to 50% of your
decisions. And then, the other 50%
of the decisions, 50 to, let's say,
30% of the decisions are
sent to an individual underwriter in
the world in order to
make a human, right?
With the advent of LLMs, a lot
of that need to have a human
individual in the
mix goes away, right?
Or gets pushed
back in the funnel.
So you can allow a
machine learning model,
which is highly
calibrated and constrained,
right? And then you--
here's the trick,
you have to blend that together
with an LLM that is highly
specified and constrained and
optimized that those two pieces
of the puzzle work
together, right? And then,
you can remove the underwriter
and use them after the decision
is made as a check, right?
So you've got a human in
the loop who is essentially making
sure that the decision
didn't have any
gaps in it, right?
Or a human that can identify
the gaps that exist in the
system so that you can improve
the system. Eventually,
what you get is that, maybe,
you've got a human that needs
to be involved 5% of the time
instead of a human that needs
to be involved 50% of the time.
And the decisions are
more consistent and create more
separation between the good risk
and the bad risk, right?
Now, the other big piece
of that puzzle is equitability.
So are you treating everyone
the same across the parameters
that matter, right?
Whether it's demographic,
whether it's race, whether
it's something else,
you've got to make sure that
you've got a human in there
that is making sure that
the AI, the LLM, and
the GLM or the machine
learning models
are actually not
introducing some specific bias
into the overall solution.
-
That was actually one of
the anonymous questions was how do
you ensure that bias is
not introduced when generating synthetic data?
- So--
it's an awesome question,
and it depends on what
you mean by bias, right?
Because there's bias,
whether it's statistical
bias or some other bias,
inherent in every single
model that's built, right?
What we try and do
is we look very closely at
the variables that are going into
all of our models,
and that's what's really
hard to do with an LLM.
I mean, you know,
somebody else almost has to
make sure that there's no bias
in the baseline LLM.
But it's all about
the covariates.
So when we're building
a machine learning model,
we're taking a look
at the covariates,
and we're making sure
that those covariates are highly
empirical and that they're
based on insurance data
for the most part.
Now, there's a lot of
demographic data that can come
in, especially in the line
of business that I'm in,
which is worker's compensation.
If anybody doesn't know what
worker's compensation is,
it's essentially
a coverage that
employers buy so that
their employees are covered
if they have an accident.
And it pays for all of
the medical bills, plus
their weekly wage as long as
they cannot get back to work at
the same world, right?
And when you think about that,
there's a lot of
demographics that come in,
things like average household
size, are actually important.
Oddly, average hail
size is as important.
And you can't imagine what
kind of biases that actually introduces.
So if you're a
homeowner's insurer,
average hail size
really matters, right?
Like the people in
Colorado, right?
They have higher premiums
than the people in
North Dakota because North
Dakota has less hail than
Colorado does, right?
Washington has less
hail than Colorado does,
whereas Washington has
different problems, right?
They have floods and things
like that. California
is highly biased
because of other things.
But what you really care about
is, is there some group of people
that already have it tough?
And are we making it more tough
because of something that's
inherent in a covariate
that we're using
that just makes it more
difficult for those people to
purchase worker's
compensation insurance?
We try as best as we can
to remove those variables,
whether it's average
wage, average household,
any race demographics, anything
like that, is completely just
dumped out of our data set
right at the beginning,
even though those exist, right?
And so, we do our best to
try and minimize those biases. But, again,
there's always going to
be inherent and potentially unknown
or unknowable biases that
actually exist within an overall
algorithm estimation. So
we do the best that we can.
Nobody's perfect at this.
There's a lot of new companies
that are coming out with novel
data like behavioral data.
And that's something that the
industry is talking about very,
very closely, right?
It's like, hey,
if we can capture what
your media content consumption is, right?
And that has a significant risk
separation between the good
risk and the bad risk.
Is it highly correlated with
things like race? Is it highly
correlated with other things?
Because it may be the case
that people have different
backgrounds, consume
different media.
And that may inherently have
some sort of correlation to
things that kind of matter
with regard to the current
zeitgeist, in terms of which groups are
having trouble and which
groups aren't, right?
And so, there's a lot
of conversation there.
- Definitely.
I see a lot of great questions
coming into the chat,
so I want to make sure I
get to some of these too.
- I'll be more concise.
- No, no, no. These are
the great discussion.
I just want to make sure I
get some of these too. But-- but,
and it's I see you had asked
a question a bit earlier in the
chat. Do you want
to jump in here?
- I think you largely
answered it, Matt.
But I was just really
interested when I went shopping
for life insurance recently
that there were some companies
that were not the biggest
companies that were able to do
everything instantly online
and didn't require things like
blood draws or physicals or any
of that kind of physical evidence.
And I was assuming that
was because they are using their
models. Or is it
just because they
are big enough that they
can kind of marginalize and don't
need to be that specific?
I'm just curious what sets up
one company to be able to do
that in one not to
be able to do that.
- There's a lot of
moving pieces there. So, generally
speaking, what I would say is,
those people who
are doing it online,
their overall rate level is
a little bit higher, right?
Because they don't have all
of the data that some of the
larger people who are not
doing it online actually have.
And so, let's say, an extremely
healthy individual, OK?
You have no medical biomarkers.
You have gone to some company
and gotten a very
extensive blood draw done,
and you have a really good
understanding of how healthy you are, right?
You're very likely going to
get a better rate with a large
company, who's not online, than
a smaller company, who's online.
Having said that,
smaller companies are using more novel
data than the older companies are,
in order to be able
to allow consumers to purchase those
types of products online.
And the rate level isn't
that different, right?
You are going to get a discount
if you get your blood drawn and
do the whole thing, if you
have extremely good biomarkers,
right? But if you
don't have extremely good biomarkers,
it's probably the
best choice for you
to go online and just get
the policy because they're going to
look at completely
different stuff.
Now,
you have to understand that
a lot of those life insurance
companies are also grabbing
a lot of that data that many
of us don't even know they're
grabbing, right?
So-- so purchasing
patterns,
media content consumption
trends, behavioral trends,
these kinds of things that
they can actually grab.
So they're using your digital
fingerprint a heck of a lot
more than they're using
your biomarkers, right?
And so, you're going
to get a higher rate,
but they can still do a
really good job of separating risk,
finding out whether you're
really interested in drinking a
lot of Jack Daniel's or whether
you're really interested in
drinking a lot of mushroom tea.
So those are going to
be very, very different.
And companies now
can use a lot of
these third-party
API aggregators in order to
get all of that information and
consume that information
through deep learning models
that are actually quite good
at separating good life insurance
risks from bad life
insurance risks.
- Thank you.
- Did that answer
your question?
- I see a thumbs-up.
So
Arafat had asked the
question. He put the star,
so I'll read it. But
it's-- the question was,
love seeing the energy
in your communication.
Do you have any tips on
how we can improve our communication?
- So,
I have been talking to large groups
of people for a very long time.
When I started, I
pictured everybody
in their underwear.
I'm sure you've heard that,
it's an old trope, right?
But
I think one of the most
important things to understand
about people, in general,
is we all put our underwear
on the same way. We
all take a number two and a
number one in exactly the same way.
I-- very early in my career,
was able to essentially
come right out of college,
and I got an underwriting
position at an insurance company
that was very small. I was
employee number five, and so,
I had direct access to the CEO since
I was right out of college.
So my working environment
did not include any social
hierarchy like
everything was flat.
And so that's what I would
encourage all of you to do is,
if you're really going
to speak your truth,
you have to be able
to punch through
the
imposter syndrome
that you might have,
the impression of a social
hierarchy that you might have.
You have to be able to talk to
a board member or a CEO in the
same way that you would talk
to a colleague because we're all
the same, we're all humans.
We all have the same needs, and
maybe
some people are smarter than
others, and that's fine.
But if you really want to do
a good job of communicating,
you have to communicate on
the same level as another individual,
which means you have to assume
that you are on the same level
as the other individual.
I would just encourage
everybody to understand that
we're all human beings.
We all have our foibles.
There's something that's
running around on LinkedIn
right now, and it is you
have to make sure that you are
really open and that you're
listening to other human
beings, not just what they're
saying but how they're saying
it. And the important reason
for that is that in anyone's
life, any other human being only
knows about 1% to 2% of
what's going on in their life.
And so,
I would just really encourage
you to empathize and consider
yourself on exactly the same level
as the people that you're talking to.
And it doesn't matter whether
they're a manager or senior
manager, a director, a
VP, or a C-level employee,
or even a board member or an
investor if you talk to them as
if you are on their same
level and they're on your same level,
you will get better
responses. I promise you,
you'll get better responses.
And I know it's easy to say,
and it's a lot harder to
do because that anxiety comes up.
If that anxiety comes up,
picture them in their underwear.
Understand that they take a crap
just like the rest of us,
right? And they've got
their own problems.
You know, I got where I
got because I was lucky.
I made a couple of
the right choices,
and I think probably 90% of
the people that are actually in
positions like mine, they
got there through dedication,
they got there through
making sure that they were
very consistent at a couple of
things that made sure that
they were person that could be
trusted, and that they were
a person that could be counted
on, right? So doing those small
things every single day is
going to do wonders for you.
Now, it's great if
you come up with a
Svengali move,
and you come up with the
greatest thing that the company
has ever seen, right? That's
sort of an added bonus.
But where you win is doing
small consistent things every single day,
and talking to everyone like they're
a brother or like their sister,
and making sure that you
are really empathizing with them
and that they know that you
have the company's interests at
heart, that you have
their interests at heart,
and that you're listening
to what their needs are.
If you can do that,
then you will become much more
confident in how you speak
very, very quickly.
Now, I will say, I've got
a lot of bombast you--
my wife tells me,
again and again,
that I'm the only person she's
ever met that doesn't give a
crap what anybody
else says about them.
And that's completely true.
I just don't worry about
my image that much.
I worry about
being a good human.
I don't worry about being
a pretty human or professional
human or the smartest
human on the planet.
I just worry about being
the good human that people can
trust and that people can
count on, and that's it.
-
What you just said about
doing those small consistent things
was reminding me of that video I
saw you just posted on LinkedIn about
being an effective leader
isn't just like going to the
leadership workshop one time a
year and saying, OK, well, I'm
trained on being a leader.
And so,
I was also wondering,
like, what are other
things that you think
make someone an effective leader?
- So,
there's a couple of things
that I posted on LinkedIn.
Some of them are quite old.
There was one that I posted
that-- and I'm sure
everybody's seen this,
the difference between a
boss and a leader, right?
A boss sits behind you with a
whip and yells at you to get
stuff done. And a leader is
the one who's pulling you along.
He's or she is the one who is
removing the blocks, who is
actually serving the employees.
And I consider myself,
and I'm a strong believer
in servant leadership, right? I'm
not anybody's boss.
I am the person who is
responsible for making sure
that all of the
conditions are set up,
so that each and every one of
my employees can succeed and can fully
explore
the domain of
their competencies.
That's my job, right?
My job is to find smart
people, and then set up the conditions,
and get the heck
out of the way.
And if there's a blocker
that is in their way,
I need to go find a way
to remove that blocker,
right? Now, are there
performance reviews and things
like that? Yeah, every
company has them.
I am a strong
proponent against them.
So I hate performance reviews.
I think that performance
reviews should be done every
single day between the
individuals that are working
together. And I don't think it
should be between a boss and
that boss's employees,
I think it should be
the individuals on--
that their colleagues on the
team that are working together
with one another.
That's where that feedback
should be coming from.
It should be a 360-degree
feedback because performance
reviews are a thing that
can be weaponized so easily.
And they say more about
the person who's giving the review
than they do about the
person who's being reviewed, period.
That is my position.
Now,
I'm happy to argue with
anyone about that particular position
because of how strongly I
actually believe in that position.
I think that if we
can create an egalitarian society where
everyone is responsible to
everyone else and everyone is
giving constant feedback to everyone else
on how to improve with empathy
and with honesty,
that is where you can create
an organization or a social
structure and a social
hierarchy that actually allows
everyone to win, and
allows everyone to succeed,
and allows everyone to explore all
of the levels of Maslow's hierarchy.
That's how you become
fully human and fully yourself.
- Thank you, Matt.
I promise I will get to
some of the other insurance questions,
but I want to be selfish for
just a second here and ask a
question. When you said part
of the role in a leader is
removing some of those
blockers for your team.
And I'm wondering for some of us
here who maybe are in a role
where we've identified
certain blockers for us,
how would you
recommend you go about
sharing that with your
leadership to kind of get past
those roadblocks?
- Whether it's an I or
a we, right? Sometimes,
there's a blocker for a
whole team. And sometimes,
there's a blocker for
an individual, right?
I think what you
need to do is--
I don't know if any of
you have taken any courses in nonviolent
communication, it's
kind of a big thing now.
We've taken a lot in
nonviolent communication.
I don't believe all of it,
but I think it is a toolset
where you can sort of mix and
match some of the tools
that come out of nonviolent communication.
One of those things is to
listen for needs and to express
needs, right? So
you start with,
I'm trying to do
this for the company.
I believe that this is going to
be very valuable, do you agree? Right?
So, first,
you've got to get buy-in on
what you're trying to do is
valuable for the organization
and valuable for the company.
The second thing is,
in order to do that,
I have certain needs
that are not being met.
This is what those needs are--
it could be an individual,
could be a group of
individuals, it could be a
dynamic, it could be
technology that isn't there,
it could be budget, it could
be whatever, right? And then,
you really express
that as a need,
not as a so-and-so is doing
something to me, and I'm mad, right?
That's a very-- sort of
a selfish communication.
What you want to do is you
want to try to abstract that as much
as you can. Now,
you can't always because
sometimes there's just a person
who isn't on board, right?
And so, you say, look,
I really need this
person to be on board,
but I don't think this
person is on board.
And I want to ask you what we
can do together in order to try and
identify that other person's needs
and discover why it is
that they appear to be a
blocker. It may be in my own
head, and I'm just-- I'm
just in an echo chamber.
But let's have
that conversation.
And if you don't feel
confident having that conversation yourself,
go to someone who you think
can have that conversation.
And it doesn't have
to be a manager,
it could be a colleague
who knows that person really well,
and can set up that meeting
so that you can have that meeting
and identify what
those needs are.
There's another book that
I would really strongly
recommend, and unfortunately, it's
escaping me right now.
The guy's name is Chris Voss,
it's called Never
Split The
Difference, I don't know if
any of you have read that.
I strongly encourage
you to read that book.
Some of it's throwaway, right?
But you know I follow
the Pareto principle,
so there's always 20% of
absolutely fantastic nuggets in every book.
So that book basically
teaches you to get to know.
You talk to an individual, and
you have a dialogue with them.
You have a dialectic with them,
until you get to why they're
saying no to whatever thing you
want to get through, right?
Because yeses that aren't
really yeses, don't matter.
You have to get
to the no, right?
And so, that--
I think making sure that you
understand what the other
person's needs are.
Or the organization's
needs, if that's a blocker,
and then making sure that
you're constructing the right conversation,
and you're having
those conversations through an
expression of needs on
both sides, a reciprocal
expression of needs. Usually,
that is the Black Swan that
will bust right through that blocker.
- Amazing. Thank you so
much, Matt. That's incredibly helpful.
Jumping back over to some
of the questions in the chat.
Alan, I see you had a question
around some of the
regulatory requirements.
Do you want to jump in here?
- Yeah, sure, thanks. This
is really, really interesting today.
That kind of following on the
thread that you started with about
these opportunities coming from
data to democratize this industry.
I wonder if there's
a counterpart
regulatory piece that you see.
Are there regulatory gaps in
that being able to be
successful in this industry
that you describe as being
a monopolistic cabal?
Are there regulatory things
that you think are really
important either for
consumer protection or for
pushing back against
anticompetitive, kind of,
practices that would
make a difference?
- Yes. And this is where
my opinions are probably
the most provocative.
I believe that, by and large,
insurance is massively
over-regulated, massively, to
the point that it's actually
been regulated in such a way
that it's extremely difficult for
new entrants to get in, right?
I think we've democratized some of
it with a lot of the things
that companies like Valen
have done and other companies
constructing consortium data sets.
But the regulatory world
in insurance is extremely
antiquated. It is--
they're basically operating on
1970s principle, by and large.
And those principles were set
up by the insurance industry at
that time, which was populated by
a very few, extremely large carriers,
specifically for the purposes
of creating barriers to
entry for new entrants.
So,
I believe all of
the regulations need to be
completely rewritten,
and they need to be completely
rewritten in view of the latest
technologies.
There is something that one
has to understand about insurance,
and that is that
I don't-- it is an
asymmetric information game.
The insurance carrier
gets to ask questions.
And they have to ask
questions mostly through a third party,
through the insurance
agent, right? And so,
not only do you have
information asymmetry, but you
have information distortion
as well. And so, what the
insurance companies are trying to
do is put themselves on a
level playing field because
the insured has all of the
knowledge about what their exposures
and what the risks are.
The insurance agent has
probably 20% of that information,
and the insurance carrier
probably has about 10% of that
information. A lot of
what's coming available now
is actually increasing that
10% to maybe 30% or 35% of the
information. There's still
a conscientious disagreeable
people out there that are
lying about all of their information.
They're a roofer,
and they're saying that
they're a computer programming company.
They're a trucker,
and they're saying that
they're a retail shop, right?
And that--
that's where we're models
are actually quite good at
determining whether someone is actually
lying to you or not,
and identifying and shaving
down the moral hazard.
Now, having said that,
there are still ways now,
and will be ways in the future,
that insurance companies can
take advantage of information
that the insurer doesn't
even know they have. And so,
I think that information transparency is
a huge piece of the puzzle.
I think that if an
insurance company is making a decision,
letting the insurer
know what decision--
what information they're using
in order to render
that decision,
is probably going to be very
important in the future.
But I think that the
regulations around machine
learning and filing models with
the Department of Insurance and
the scrutiny that they have
to go through is massively, like,
exponentially slowing down the
innovation that could occur in
the insurance industry.
It's also why most insurance
companies that I've worked with
are choosing not to
file their models.
There are very few people
that are actually filing models in
the commercial insurance space.
In the personal auto space
or the personal life space,
you have to file
all of your models.
So the Department of
Insurance gets to look at it,
they get to scrutinize it,
they can say no on just
about anything and they do.
And there are some states that
don't even allow for trade secrets.
So once you have to file
your model with the Department of Insurance,
your competitor can actually get
all of that information and
rebuild your model, which
I've done several times.
So I think there needs
to be massive changes
in regulation around
data science, machine learning,
and algorithms, and
how they're used
in determining pricing
and availability of
insurance coverage.
But I think it also needs to
be in light of the fact that
insurance carriers are playing
an information asymmetric game.
We do not have as much
information as we need in order
to render the best
possible coverage and pricing decision
on an individual
business. And really,
that's what we're trying to do.
We're essentially
buying used cars.
And we have to figure out
whether that used car has had
something bad that seller
of that used car knows exactly
what's going on with that car.
We don't know exactly
what that car.
And that's what I think most
insurance carriers are trying to solve.
- Thanks there's a bunch.
that's super interesting
in a lot of perspective,
especially about
asymmetric information.
That's new for me to think
about. Appreciate hearing it. Thank you.
- Absolutely.
- AJ, I see you had a
question in the chat as well.
Do you want to jump in here?
- Sure, yeah. I wanted to get
your opinion on, and see how far
some of these job
functions being automated,
such as underwriting
or app input
because AI is so much advanced,
and it's reading so much
data from your database, vast
databases, so
what are your thoughts on that?
- Yeah. So there's-- I
don't believe that all risks. And
now, with
the latest technology,
my opinion is changing,
sort of,
actively as I start to
understand a little bit more
about these LLMs.
You know, in
Transformers and the like.
I believe that probably
85% to 90%,
maybe even 95% of the
underwriting decisions that are
currently being made by
human beings in the world,
will be eliminated through the
use of machine learning and AI.
I mean, that's
just a simple fact.
It is already the case
that machine learning models can
make significantly better and
more consistent decisions than
humans.
Now, it is game
theoretic, right? So what
the models are not quite
as good yet at doing,
and obviously, there's ways
to solve this using models.
They're not quite as good
at understanding the market conditions,
and the changing market
conditions with regard to what
the best price might be, right?
Insurance carriers have to be
able to understand good risk
from bad risk, but they
also have to write policies, right?
And that means that sometimes
you have to make trade-offs.
And that's where
human beings come in.
They're making
those trade-offs.
They're saying, well,
I might write this at a
slightly higher loss ratio.
But if I don't write this
packet of business, a
slightly higher loss ratio,
I'm not going to have
enough revenue, right?
So the game theoretic, piece
of the puzzle sort of price
optimization, which is
a really bad word in
insurance, but that's
how we think, right?
We're actually doing price
optimization every single day.
It's just that we're
doing it through human underwriters.
I think where the world is
going to go in insurance is
that a lot of the customer
service personnel are going to
be eliminated because LLMs are going
to take on that. You know, Chatbots
and RPA and automation are
going to be able to do probably
95% to 100% of policy
changes endorsements, things like that.
But on the underwriting side,
I think that it will probably
eliminate 85% to 90% of the
decisions that doesn't mean
that the underwriter's role
gets eliminated.
It means that the underwriter's
role changes significantly.
It changes to a portfolio
management role. It changes to
a gap identification role.
And it changes to a role where
an underwriter is now the
subject matter expert that
works directly with the data
science team in order to
identify and explore the gaps
that may exist in
the model solutions,
and helps to fill
those with novel data
and perspective that sometimes a
lot of the data science teams
don't have because they're
not on the front lines.
And that's sort of
a surrogate is--
it is really important in
insurance that the data science
team actually has a working
knowledge of the line of
business that they're actually
looking at. So if you are
building a model for commercial
auto, you have to
understand commercial auto.
You have to understand
how it's rated,
you have to understand
the coverages, et cetera.
I have a lot of PhD data
scientists that I've worked
with in the past that
felt like, hey, I'm a data
scientist. I don't need to know
the underlying environment.
I'm just going
to grab the data,
and I'm going to build a model.
I can tell you, that
in my experience, 90%
of the models that are built
in that fashion fail because they
cannot be productionalized.
The data scientists didn't find
out whether the information was
available, at the time that
the decision needed to be made.
Or the target was not
transformed in a way that was
critically important because the
data was centered, censored,
or there was a treatment effect
that they did not identify
until after they built them up.
And they have to rebuild
the whole model over again.
- Thank you. That-- this
is kind of a follow-up
question here but talking about building
this model. There was
an anonymous question.
It was,
can you walk through how your
team approaches finding a
valuable question,
exploring that question,
building and testing
a predictive model,
and then deploying that? The
technical aspect of that?
- I'm going to try
and be concise there.
I'm not sure how
concise I can be.
- That's OK.
- So,
generally speaking, we will,
on a regular basis, go out
to each one of the Department
heads. And we will
ask them, what
are your problems today? What
is creating too much friction?
What is something
that you think
could be better decision
that's being partly decision today?
And then we'll get all
of that information back.
Once we construct all of the
quote-unquote, "potential
opportunities"
for data science,
then we start to look around at
the available data sources that we have,
and we start to do some
discovery around whether or not
we can actually solve that
particular problem with data.
Do we have the data available
to be able to solve that problem?
Is that problem a big
enough problem to solve?
So, usually, once we go
to the Department heads, we'll then,
go to the business or
department analysts within that
particular department
and say, hey,
how big of a problem is
this? Can we quantify
the friction? Can we quantify
how much this is costing us?
How many minutes? How many
hours? How many days? How
many employee
days does this take?
And what, theoretically,
if we were able to remove
that and automate that,
what would the savings
be? And then, of course,
there's other
things in insurance.
How much better can we make
around these decisions?
Whether it be, can I separate
good risk from bad risk?
Can I identify the
probability that someone's actually going
to pay their bills?
Can I identify the cost if
they don't pay their bills?
Can I identify how many times
they're not going to pay their bills?
And we've got to do
something with that policy,
whether it be to cancel
it, and reinstate it,
and all that stuff because
that cost insurance company money.
All of those different things,
even on the marketing side. So,
what is our what's our current
customer acquisition cost?
And where is it
relatively high?
And is there a way for us to
build a model in order to lower that?
So there's a wide variety of
different things that you can do. Once
you sit on a problem,
and you know that there's
enough value there,
and you know that you have the
data to be able to solve that
problem, then it's
a pretty standard process.
You have to wrangle the data,
you have to normalize the data,
you have to work together
with the Department experts in that
department to identify what
they think might be interesting
or valuable covariates, right?
So, usually,
we will do some unsupervised
modeling just to figure out
what the data
looks like, right?
Where might there be blooms
of data that could be interesting?
And then we'll do a
correlation study,
which is with as many
covariates that we can actually
put together, and then bring
that back to the Department.
And then ask the
subject matter expert,
what's not in here that you
think should be in here? Right?
And then,
they'll start to think
about and construct some additional
features, then you start
the feature engineering phase, right?
You do that with the
subject matter experts in that department,
and you try and get as
many features that you think might
be useful as possible.
And then, of course,
there's some target
transformation sometimes.
Are you going to build
a logistic model?
Are you going to
build a linear model?
Are you going to build something
that you're going to use for triage?
Is it going to be sort
of a categorical model where you've
got five or six different
decisions that need to be made,
and you're going
to split those up?
You kind of figure out what
the best sort of opportunity is there.
And then, we usually go through
sample and partitioning.
How are you going
to sample this?
What's your strategy
going to be?
What is your
validation strategy?
So are you going
to do cross-fold validation?
What's your holdout
going to look like?
What's your train set
What you're testing is
that going to look like?
Are those stratified correctly?
Is anything time series based?
Because that has a significant
impact on how you're thinking
about your sampling strategy.
Usually, in insurance,
depending on data size
and the composition of the
target, we use anywhere between
three partitions and 10
partitions, right? If it's a
more complicated problem
and we've got a lot of data,
we use up to 10 partitions,
and we'll hold three or
four of them out. And then,
we'll use incrementally, four or five
or six or seven of those
in order to increment
through the overall model-building process.
We'll use the first
partition, maybe split that up
in order to do
feature engineering,
and basic variable
selection and reduction,
then we will build
our initial model,
and then we'll test it on
the next partition. And then,
normally, what we do
is, we'll build on--
let's say you
have five different partitions.
We build on one and
two tests on three,
build on one and
three tests on two.
Build on two and three
tests on one, right?
And then once you're really
confident that you've got the
right model using that data,
you add the next partition.
Now, you've got one two,
and three built on four. Four,
three, and two, built on--
tested on one, and so
on and so forth, right?
And we're constantly
looking at coefficients,
whether they're shifting,
whether they're going up and
down. If the tree model,
we're looking at what
the splits look like.
We're sort of doing
hyperparameter selection
usually on those early partitions until
you get to the final model,
usually with two or three
validations that's already held out.
And in insurance,
we're usually using between
five and eight cross-fold
validation at each one of those stages
just to make sure that we're getting--
there's a lot of volatility because
of the zero point max in insurance.
So you really need to make
sure that you've got enough
cross-fold validation there because you
can have a very large loss
that makes things look really
weird in any one partition of
the data that
you're looking at.
Hopefully, that helps.
Because I can go on that
for like an hour and a half.
- No, thank you very much.
We threw a lot at you
with that one question.
I think we have time
for one more question.
[? Callau, ?] I
see you had asked
something a bit
earlier about training.
Do you want to jump
in with your question?
- Yeah, sure. I'm happy to
jump in. Hi, Matt. My name is
[? Callau. ?] I'm a
customer success rep here at Posit.
- She's actually my
customer success.
- Yes, for Pie Insurance.
And a few others on the
call, actually. But, yeah,
there seems to be so much
to know in this space,
not just for insurance, but
data science programming, in general.
And as somebody who might
be just starting out in industry,
or coming out of college,
how would they get
a job? I guess,
what skills or knowledge do you
think they should have? Or what
are teams like yours
looking for in new hires?
Like, do you--
- That's a really
good question.
- Yeah.
- I mean,
so, I think a working
knowledge of both Python,
and I'm going to say it,
R, right? R and Python, and a
working knowledge of both of
those is really important. The
biggest piece of the puzzle
for me is an understanding of
what I would call pragmatic
productionalizable
model building, right?
Do not
narrow your scope
or your interest down
to research alone.
You need to know how to
get models into production so that
they can be used by actors
in the real world, right?
If you're doing
descriptive statistics,
that's great. I mean-- and if
that's what you want to do, great.
But you're going to cut
yourself short if you don't
know how to deploy a model.
You're going to cut yourself
short if you don't know what
the process look like in
order to deploy a model.
You don't necessarily need to
know how to do the engineering,
right? You can get an
MLOps team for that.
But you need to know,
as a data scientist,
how to do things
like parity testing,
predictions between the
production environment and the
model build environment, right?
You need to understand
what that looks like,
with that process
looks like, right?
And you need to understand how
to actually go the last mile,
if you will, right?
If you're just building general
linear models and you're doing
that descriptively, and you're
saying, look, I built the
model, and it
looks great, right?
The next question that any
executive is going to ask you
is, OK, how do we use this?
How are we going to deploy this?
Are we going to
deploy it in SQL?
Are we going to containerize it?
Are we going to use Scala?
Are we going to do something else
in order to get that model into PMML,
whatever the case may be?
How do we get that
model into production?
And how do we know that
production model is going to
score the same way as it
did in the model build environment?
I think the other one is,
having a really good
understanding and an ability to
articulate what the model
building process looks like.
All the way from finding
the data sources,
all the way through to
validating that model and
making sure that you
don't have an over model,
and that model is really going
to perform as you say it's
going to perform in the real
world on data that it hasn't
seen before. Those are
all really, really important.
The last point
that I'll make is,
it is critically important for you to
show in any interview or to any
business manager that you have
a high level of curiosity in
the business that
you're in. Don't
sell yourself short, and
just be a data scientist.
You need to be a curious
data scientist. If it's an
insurance, you need to want
to learn insurance. If it's in
Aeronautics, you need to
want to learn Aeronautics.
If it's in process optimization
for-- I don't know,
making candy bars,
you need to really be curious
and interested in what the
process looks like to
make a candy bar, right?
I think that that's really,
really important is that data
scientists can't just be data
scientists. They have to
be Renaissance people,
and constantly curious,
and autodidactic.
That-- that's the best advice
that I can give
is, don't narrow
yourself. Don't be
an inch wide and a mile deep.
Be a mile wide and
more than a few inches deep.
- Great. Thanks, Matt.
- Yep.
- Thank you so much, Matt.
I know we quickly came to
the top of the hour here.
But I really appreciated
this conversation,
and you jumping on
here and joining us.
- Absolutely my pleasure.
I had a fun time.
Thank you all for all
the great questions too.
I'm going to put
Matt's LinkedIn in the
chat here if anybody wants to
connect. But also,
I will share the recording of
course to YouTube and to the
Posit Data Science Hangout
site. Have a great rest of the
day, everybody.